the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we're now at story board 23 let's look
at panel a our last metabolism topic
under the general umbrella of catabolism
is ketone bodies ketone bodies are only
covered in two pages in the book but
they're medically very important the
medical relevance of ketone bodies stems
from their role in starvation and their
role in diabetes let's look at panel a
this panel shows various sources of and
uses of acetyl co a it shows that ketone
bodies are made from acetyl coenzyme a
so let's start this part of the lecture
with a discussion of where acetyl co a
comes from and what its various fates
are including the formation of ketone
bodies we just finished talking about
fatty acid catabolism so let's start on
the right of this figure we see that a
fatty acid can be broken down to form
acetyl co a by beta oxidation usually
with the objective of generating energy
if we follow the acetyl co a from beta
oxidation down into the TCA cycle we see
that it will be fully oxidized to carbon
dioxide with the generation of a lot of
energy that can be used for mechanical
work biosynthesis and other things a
second source of acetyl co a can be seen
to the left where we see glycogen
breakdown to glucose or glucose can be
directly imported into a cell in either
case the glucose that we take in or
liberate from its storage depot glycogen
can be converted into acetyl coenzyme a
glycerol can be generated from the
backbone of a metabolized tri acyl
glyceride it enters glycolysis as
dihydroxyacetone phosphate and then can
progress to acetyl co a by way of
glycolysis alanine can trans emanate
into pyruvate which is converted
subsequently diacetyl away by pyruvate
dehydrogenase this diagram shows us that
many pathways converge to generate
acetate Oh
enzyme a carbohydrates amino acids fatty
acids all can act as a source of this
important precursor to energy aside from
being processed by the TCA cycle on the
Left we see a broken line pathway
involving fatty acid biosynthesis this
is going to be the next topic we come to
after this discussion of ketone body
formation the pathway on the right with
the broken lines is the pathway leading
to ketone bodies which is called
ketogenesis in the box at the top of
panel a is a cartoon reminding me to
tell you that as a Toa cannot escape
from the cell moreover it cannot even
easily escape from the mitochondrion in
order for acid Toa to leave the cell and
be transported from one organ to another
needs to be converted into ketone bodies
another way to look at keep cone bodies
is that these are mobile or portable
forms of acetyl co a that can go from a
source organ which is usually the liver
to a target organ which may need them in
order to generate energy by way of the
TCA cycle the target organ for example
could be brain under conditions of
starvation or could be skeletal muscle
if you have to run away from something
let's look at panel B there are five key
facts that we need to know about ketone
bodies first ketogenesis mainly occurs
in the liver the liver manufactures
ketone bodies and then exports them to
other organs for use these reactions
typically happen when the levels of
oxaloacetate become limiting in their
mitochondria and I'll give you an
example of why this is the case when I
talk about starvation a little later in
this lecture
the second important fact is that these
are the primary metabolic fuels of the
heart and skeletal muscle under normal
conditions the third fact is that ketone
bodies become the major metabolic fuel
of all cells under conditions of
starvation even cells of the brain after
a few days of starvation will convert
from glucose being the preferred
metabolic fuel to accepting ketone
bodies as their major source of energy
the fourth fact I want to talk about
with regard to ketone bodies is that
they're produced in excess in diabetes
I'll talk a little bit more about that
later in the lecture
finally ketogenesis occurs in the
mitochondrion primarily the
mitochondrion of the liver so these are
reactions panel see shows the three
classical ketone bodies acetoacetate
beta-hydroxybutyrate
and acetone from the standpoint of
chemical accuracy it's obvious that beta
hydroxy butyrate is an alcohol and not a
ketone
nevertheless it's lumped in with the
ketone bodies for historical reasons
acetoacetate and beta-hydroxybutyrate
are what i'll call quote unquote useful
ketone bodies from the standpoint of
serving as precursors to metabolic
energy acetone by contrast is not useful
by this criterion acetone however is a
useful biomarker because sometimes its
presence can help diagnose diabetes on a
personal note I come from a long line of
diabetics I remember when I was a little
kid my dad before he was diagnosed would
come home from work at the end of the
day he had very poor circulation so my
two sisters and I would try to rub his
legs to give him a kind of massage to
make his circulation a little bit better
I remember very clearly my older sister
saying gee dad smells like mom's nail
polish remover and that's because he was
a diabetic producing acetone which was
used at the time at least as nail polish
remover we had no idea at the time what
was going on a few months later my dad
was diagnosed as a type two diabetic I
now know that the fruity odor we smelled
on his breath was acetone as I said
acetone is a biomarker of this disease
one last point with regard to this
storyboard
note that the acetoacetate and
beta-hydroxybutyrate molecules are acids
and diabetics these acids can be
produced as we'll see letter later in
sufficiently high concentrations to
lower the pH of the blood quite
substantially keep in mind that lowering
the pH is the same thing as increasing
the concentration of protons in the
blood these concentrated protons will
have physiological relevance that I'll
discuss later when a diabetic enters the
phase where the pH of their blood is
dangerously low that's called diabetic
acidosis let's now turn to panel D at
this point I want to describe the
detailed biochemical reactions to give
rise to ketone bodies
to make a ketone body we're going to
need three molecules of acetone coenzyme
a one of these molecules is going to be
catalytic that is it's going to be
restored at the overall end of the
process of ketogenesis let's start by
imagining a scenario in the
mitochondrion of a liver cell where
oxaloacetate becomes limiting I'll talk
about physiological states under which
oxaloacetate becomes limiting or sparse
a little bit later acetyl co a cannot
enter the TCA cycle because citrate
synthase lacks oxaloacetate is a
reaction partner the concentration of
sotl co a starts to accumulate then the
beta key to Theo lays reaction that is
the last step in fatty acid biotoxin
reverses owing to the high concentration
of product acetic away so two acetyl co
a s come together in order to form
acetyl acetate coenzyme a note that i
put markers on each of the carbons of
the acetoacetate coenzyme a a third
acetyl coenzyme a is then added to the
gamma carbon of the acid acetoacetate
coenzyme a that's the carbon that has
the filled in square the enzyme to
catalyze this last reaction is h mg
coenzyme a reductase where H M G stands
for hydroxymethyl gluta real hmg-coa is
a six carbon branched chain molecule in
the present situation we're going to
look at h mg Co a as the source of
ketone bodies in the mitochondrion but I
want you to keep in mind that if this
reaction were to occur not in the
mitochondrion but in the cytoplasm the
resulting hm g co a could be used for
other pathways for example hmg-coa in
the cytosol is the precursor to
cholesterol with that in mind let's
return our attention to the
mitochondrion and ketogenesis the
mitochondrial enzyme hm g co a lie a's
will split the hm g co a knocking off an
asset Eelco a in liberating as the final
product acetoacetate which is our first
of three ketone bodies acetyl acetate is
a beta keto acid in hence prone to
spontaneous decarboxylation non
enzymatically this will happen at some
slow rate in order
to liberate co2 and produce acetone
which is our second ketone body this
acetone gives the fruity smell to the
breath of a diabetic whose disease is
out of control
acetone is not going to be biochemically
useful to us for example it's not going
to be metabolized to generate energy
the second chemical fate of the
acetoacetate is its reduction by nadh
using the enzyme beta hydroxy butyrate
dehydrogenase this reduction forms our
third ketone body beta hydroxy butyrate
which is a biochemical useful molecule
in that it serves as a good metabolic
fuel acetoacetate and
beta-hydroxybutyrate do not need any
kind of special transporter to get out
of the cell into the blood they diffuse
through the mitochondrial membrane and
later through the cell membrane
they are then transported by the
circulatory system from the liver to
organs that need them for energy as I
mentioned above ketone bodies are
portable forms of acetyl co a in a real
sense the liver by making these ketone
bodies is acting as a food caterer where
ketone bodies represent food that's
delivered to other organs at this point
let's look at storyboard 24 panel a now
let's take a look what happens when the
ketone bodies travel by the blood and
are taken up by another organ such as
muscle acetoacetate which I'll refer to
as ketone body one is good to go and is
ready to enter the mainstream of
metabolism so I'm going to come back to
it in a minute the beta hydroxy butyrate
by contrast has to be processed in order
for it to be useful to the target organ
skeletal muscle in this case in step two
the muscle form of beta hydroxy butyrate
dehydrogenase will use nad plus to
oxidize the beta hydroxy butyrate into
acetyl acetate which joins the pool of
acetoacetate that came in directly from
the blood we now have to put a thio
ester group on the acetoacetate and that
comes from an unusual source in step 3
you'll see a suction Neil Cleanse I'm a
from the TCA cycle giving it's coenzyme
a residue to acetoacetate which results
in the formation of acetyl acetate
coenzyme a this reaction happens
the mitochondrion of the cell at step
four acetoacetate coenzyme a is
converted by beta theta beta keto
thiolase into two molecules of sotl
coenzyme a and again we're going to need
another coenzyme a group to come in at
this point as part of the beta keto
thiolase reaction remember that beta key
to thiolate is the last enzyme that's
operative in beta oxidation of fatty
acids here it's doing the same chemistry
that it does in beta oxidation it splits
acetoacetate co a into two acetyl co a
molecules and it steps five and six
those molecules integrate into the TCA
cycle in the TCA cycle they're oxidized
to carbon dioxide with the generation of
energy let me review for a minute before
going into a physiological scenario way
over to the left at step one the liver
has made acetic away and packaged it
into two ketone bodies acetoacetate and
beta-hydroxybutyrate they travel in the
blood to target tissues for example the
muscle or heart or the brain in these
target tissues these ketone bodies are
internalized converted to acetyl acetate
and then to acetyl acetate coenzyme a
and then ultimately to several molecules
of acetone coenzyme a the acetyl
coenzyme a that started in the liver
ends up in the target tissue and then
can be used to generate energy this is a
particularly important reaction under
conditions of starvation and diabetes
let's now look at panel B of storyboard
24 as you know I like to look at
physiological scenarios because at least
to me they help make biochemistry real
the scenario I want to look at is that
of diabetes and type 2 diabetes which is
the type that I have my cells have
become resistant to taking up glucose my
cells are insulin insensitive after a
meal I have very very high
concentrations of glucose in my blood
because the cells of my tissues are not
capable of taking it in hence if I do
not take my anti diabetic medication the
sugar concentration by blood stays high
which leads to some of the medical
complications of die
beetus more on that later given that
there's a lot of glucose in my blood but
it's not getting into my cells my cells
are actually in a technical state of
starvation take a look at the pathway
I've drawn in panel B glucose on the
left is not getting into the cell I've
used broken lines for the pathway from
glucose to pyruvate and then from
pyruvate in the cytoplasm into the
mitochondrial matrix these broken lines
are meant to indicate that the pathways
involved are just not very active the
sparse activity of these pathways means
that asset Eelco weight levels are
becoming somewhat limiting in the
mitochondrion because pyruvate is also
limiting the enzyme pyruvate carboxylase
doesn't have sufficient pyruvate in
order to maintain the oxaloacetate
concentration within the mitochondrial
matrix once again oxaloacetate is the
TCA cycle intermediate that that's at
the lowest that is micro molar
concentration I'm focusing here on the
liver although I should add at this
point that all tissues are similarly
limited in the pathways indicated by the
broken lines the livers response to
sensing this limitation in carbohydrate
processing is to either take in lipid or
to break it down from internal stores
for example triacylglycerols in order to
produce acetic away but because
oxaloacetate is limiting the step at
beta keto thiolase backs up producing a
large amount of ketone bodies the ketone
bodies are produced in excess so you can
see them escaping into the mitochondrion
and later out of the cell and they go
off into the blood consequently the
liver of diabetics produces a lot of
ketone bodies because it's senses that
the body is starving to the right of
panel B I have some blood chemistry
values that are of relevance to
diabetics in a non diabetic person blood
sugar concentrations that is blood
glucose is maintained at about 100
milligrams of glucose per 100
milliliters of blood when I was
diagnosed with diabetes my blood sugar
was over 300 milligrams for 100
milliliters as I recall the symptoms
were disorientation I couldn't walk very
easily
I was thirst
d and I urinated a lot normal ketone
body concentrations are less than 0.2
nano molar in a severe diabetic
situation your ketone body
concentrations could be 15 to 25 milli
molar and the pH of your blood could
drop from the mid 7 to 8 the kidney
responds to the high concentration of
glucose in the high concentration of
protons that is the low pH by increasing
urine volume output in order to try to
urinate out the glucose and protons the
results are that the diabetic becomes
excessively thirsty which again is one
of the biomarkers or symptoms of the
disease the classic historical treatment
of diabetes is to give insulin which
will push more glucose into the cell and
thus offset the biochemical defect that
leads ultimately to ketone bodies and to
the high concentration of glucose in the
blood aside from giving insulin by
injection there are other medications
that will result in a sort of
reactivation of the beta cells of the
pancreas in order to produce more
insulin naturally alternatively there
are medications that will block
gluconeogenesis and the stop the ability
to liver and other gluconeogenic organs
from producing glucose so by blocking
gluconeogenesis one can lower the
glucose concentration of the blood as
you'll see there are many many ways to
treat this disease let me add that it
can be a very debilitating disease
leading to blindness amputation and
cardiovascular difficulties it's a good
idea to try to avoid the risk factors
for this disease it's not fully
preventable at least in people who come
from families in which nearly everybody
gets it for example my situation but by
avoiding risk factors you can push off
the date of onset by many years